let's talk about today's mass shooting
i guess it's actually yesterday's
but what a country
that when we say
the mass shooting i i have to speculate
not the one from last tuesday
and not the one from the previous
weekend
i'm talking about the one from yesterday
another
horrifying event
four people have been killed in a mass
shooting at a tulsa oklahoma
it's sometimes being discussed this
described as a hospital maybe more
accurately a medical building
the gunman is also dead cbs news has
um
a report that contains much of the
information we now know four people were
killed in a shooting last night
wednesday evening in a medical building
on a hospital campus in tulsa oklahoma
the gunman is also dead apparently from
a self-inflicted gunshot wound
tulsa police department captain richard
muellenberg told cnn multiple people
were wounded he said it was fewer than
ten no one had wounds considered
life-threatening so four dead
the shooter dead
an additional up to 10 people wounded
with non-life-threatening injuries he
told the associated press that the
medical complex was a quote catastrophic
scene
the identities of the victims and the
gunmen haven't been released as of this
moment
by the time this story publishes
maybe some of that will have been
released the motive wasn't immediately
known the shooting occurred a little
before five on the campus of saint
francis hospital officers were there
within three minutes made contact with
the gunman within another five minutes
um
the police chief says i was very happy
with what we know so far
regarding the response of our officers
certainly
an allusion
to the response at the texas shooting
for sure
officers encountered encountered the
suspect on the second floor of the
hospital's natalie building
the gunman is a black male believed to
be between 35 and 40 armed with a long
gun and a handgun both weapons appeared
to have been fired the officers that did
arrive were hearing shots in the
building and that's what directed them
to the second floor so listen this is
this is another one of these things
where
the the details are catastrophic
the death toll is tragic
um it's it's just it's yet another
shooting but as always i find it
important to remind you that there have
now been 20 mass shootings since last
week's shooting in texas this is sort of
like the next mass shooting that made
the news in a national way
but if you look at
gunviolencearchive.org and you go back
to the day of the texas shooting where
of course 22 were killed and 17 injured
there was a shooting in philly in
stanwood michigan in anniston alabama
memphis tennessee colorado springs one
in florida one in california another one
in tennessee chicago henderson nevada on
and on and on
there have been 20 of these there was a
shooting just two days ago in charleston
south carolina where thankfully no one
was killed but 10 individuals were
injured waco texas had a shooting with
four people injured on
tuesday and then we get to this shooting
yesterday in tulsa oklahoma with five
killed that includes the shooter the
number injured has not yet been updated
on
gunviolencearchive.org so it is not you
know it would be bad enough if we had
the buffalo shooting and the texas
shooting and the tulsa shooting
but in between that we've had dozens
more shootings and it just doesn't stop
now after the break
i'm going to be speaking
with democratic congressman jamie raskin
many of you have said david you should
really talk to jamie raskin he's a true
progressive and he really cares and if
anybody's going to get things done in
this congress it's going to be jamie
raskin well i'm going to speak to him
after the break
and one of the questions i have for him
because we've been hearing anecdotally
this time it's different
this time it's going to be a different
thing it's not going to be
the same again
i'm going to ask jamie raskin is there
actually any willingness from
republicans to do something about gun
safety regulations this time or is it
going to be that same vicious cycle of
thoughts and prayers and no we can't
touch guns that we've seen so many times
before that's after the break make sure
to find us on instagram david pakman
show
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries is curiosity
stream one of our sponsors if you love
documentaries like me
you should really check out
curiositystream they've got all the
newest and best documentary titles tons
of stuff i can't find on netflix or hulu
and curiositystream is only 125 a month
when you use my link below if you're
looking for those new award-winning
documentaries they've got them if you're
looking for the classics from years ago
they have those as well i just watched a
fantastic documentary called deep time
history which goes into
early
like pre-history
fascinating and curiosity stream has an
app for all of your devices tv phone
computer
whether you want to watch a serene
nature documentary on the couch or check
out a juicy political corruption story
curiosity stream has you covered you can
get curiosity stream for 15 bucks a year
that's a dollar 25 a month only when you
go to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below